Hong Kong's Hang Seng index for example was
down today after official data showed that
China's Exports dropped by more than 4% in
December, compared to the same period a year
earlier.
It's the biggest drop in two years.
China's global trade surplus also sank last
year, according to Chinese customs figures.
But, crucially China's trade surplus with
the US jumped by more than 17% - prompting
fears that US president Donald Trump might
feel the need to crank upt the heat in the
simmering trade conflict between the world's
two biggest economies.
China's weaker imports also worry analysts,
raising concerns the world economy might be
on track for a slowdown.
Signs of an economic slowdown in China have
been hard to miss.
And since the beginning of the year, the effects
are being felt elsewhere, too.
In Britain last week , Jaguar LandRover said
it's cutting 4,500 jobs, due to a dramatic
drop off in sales in China.
There was also a sharp sell off on global
equity markets
when Apple issued a profit warning due to
flagging Iphone sales in the world's second
largest economy.
Shares in other companies heavily invested
in China also dropped after word got out that
demand is softening.
The global economy only now seems to be waking
up to the fact that growth is slowing fast
in China.
GDP growth by some accounts will drop to just
over six percent by next year.
China will remain a fast growing economy compared
to many other nations.
But a slowdown now means a lot more than
it would have a couple of decades ago.
That's because back then, China's surging
economy accounted for only a small part of
.. global economic performance.
But today, it's nearly twenty percent.
That means China's growth doesn't have to
cool too much, before things get really hot
in the countries who do business with it.